هذه الضربات تسببت في انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي في اكثر من مدينه اوكرانيه
نعم بالفعل توفيق همم تقريبا معظم المناطق
الاوكرانيه دخلت في الظلام الدامس بسبب
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي تقريبا هذا
المنعرج هو منعرج حاسم بالنسبه للوضع
الوضع الطاقي في اوكرانيا بدات بالضربات
في الاسابيع المقبله ولكن اليوم كذلك تعرض
في مدينه كيا وتحديداشات الطاقه في مدينه
كيرلي ضربات ما ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
وجرح اخرين همم تقريبا مدينه كيف والريف
وكذلك هنا
عدد من المدن الكبرى والمناطق المحيطه بها
انقطع عليها التيار الكهربائي وعندما نقول
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في ان ذلك يلقي
بظلاله اعلى خدمات اخرى مثل انقطاع وسائل
التدفئه وكذلك وسائل الاتصال وشبكه
الانترنت التي تشهد ضعفا كبيرا في الوقت
الحالي وكذلك في الماء خاصه في مدينه كيب
وحتى هنا في اوديسا نفتقد الى الماء
باعتبار ان امي مضخات الماء تستوجب الطاقه
الكهربائيه هذه هذا الانقطاع الطلاق ايضا
مولدافيا المجاوره والتي مرتبطه ايضا
بشبكه الطاقه في اوكرانيا ربما الوضع قد
يزداد سوءا وذلك حسب مدير شركه الكهرباء
الاوكرانيه والذي قال ان منشات الطاقه
متضرره بشكل كبير في ظل انقطاع ايضا
الكهرباء الثلاثه مفاعلات نوويه في جنوب
اوكرانيا نعم توفيق
استخدام تقريبا
نعم بالفعل الوضع الامني كذلك يتساقم تم
استخدام 70 صاروخ وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع انها اسقطت ما لا
يقل عن واحد 55 صاروخا من هذه الصواريخ
هذا اليوم
الهجومات طالت عده
الصباح الذي استهدفت فيه قوه الروسيه
مستشفى وخاصه قسم التوليد ما ادى الى مقتل
اراضيها حديث الولاده عمره يومين كذلك همم
هناك قصف في مدينه خلصن ومتواصل كل يوم
تقريبا همم
الشباب الذي يبلغ عمره 13 عاما همم
ده بحياته همم تضررا لجراحه في المستشفى
كذلك عده هجمات اخرى
كذلك همم
وحتى في منطقه ايضا نعم التوفيق شكرا لك
وسيم الدالي من
قدساه